- You had a podcast not long ago
where you were talking about
how Dawkins basically
said that, well,
religion does have some
benefits to society.
And I think he's realizing too
that in Britain in particular,
a tepid secularism is not
gonna resist a radical Islam,
but Christianity could be
just from a pragmatic point,
point of view, from
his point of view,
can maybe blunt radical Islam.
So he's realizing there's some
pragmatic uses to religion.
But I think originally the
new atheism came out of 9/11,
these fundamentalists,
you know the old saying
that science will teach
you how to fly a plane,
but religion will teach you
how to fly a plane
into a building.
You know, that kind of thing.
And so they were really
adamant against any religion,
and they would put
'em all together.
Islam, Christianity, all these
religions are just basically
looked at with
disdain at the time.
And I think people
starting to realize
that's not really the
way the world works.
That's not really true.
These religions are different,
and they're different
for good reasons.
(light jazzy music)
- All right, we are
at the local studio
here in Miami, Florida,
and joining me
today is the author
of "I Don't Have Enough
Faith to Be An Atheist."
Great title, man.
Frank Turek,
pleasure to meet you.
- Dave, it is a pleasure.
Great being here with you.
- Thanks for coming to town.
You've come from
Charlotte, North Carolina.
- Yes, sir.
- I appreciate you
making the trek.
Let's start with the
title of this book.
"I Don't Have Enough
Faith to Be An Atheist."
- I didn't think of
it. My co-author did.
- So I should say you are
technically the co-author
of this book.
Tell me a little bit about your.
- Well, Dr. Norman Geisler,
when he died, he
died in 2019, Dave,
they added up the number
of books he either wrote,
co-wrote or updated, it was 129.
The man had written more books,
not only than most
people have read,
than most people have seen,
'cause who goes to
library anymore, right?
This guy was brilliant,
and at one point he and I
were traveling the country
doing a talk we called
"The 12 Points That Show
Christianity's True."
And he went through the
fine-tuning argument
that the universe is fine
tuned so incomprehensibly,
and after he got done with
this amazing presentation,
he finally said,
"In light of this,
I just don't have enough
faith to be an atheist."
And I went, "That needs to
be the title of the book."
- So it really was
a throwaway line.
- Yeah, he just said,
"I don't have enough
faith to be an atheist."
So he said, "Well,
let's write the book."
So we wrote the book based
on the seminar we were doing.
We sent it to the
publisher, and they said,
"We don't like the title."
I said, "You don't
like the title?
What do you think
the title should be?"
And they said, "The
Truth About Truth."
I said, "Sorry,
that's a deal breaker.
We're going to
another publisher."
They said, "Okay, we'll
stick with the title."
And thankfully they did.
- And the book came out in 2004.
Tell me a little bit
about how you two
linked up your journeys
to get to the book,
and then we'll dive into
obviously the specifics
of why you don't have enough
faith to be an atheist.
- I was in the Navy,
which stands for never
again volunteer yourself,
for eight years.
And, but I came to
faith by reading books
by a man by the name
of Josh McDowell.
I was brought up in New
Jersey, so I was Catholic,
'cause as you know, in
Jersey it's the law.
You're either Catholic
or Jewish, right?
I went to Catholic high school,
but I never knew who Jesus was.
And when I was in the Navy,
I met the son of a
Methodist minister,
and I had so many
questions for me.
He said, "Frank, you just need
to get Josh McDowell books,
evidenced demands a verdict
more than a carpenter."
So I read those books,
and I began to realize that
Christianity is indeed true.
When I got out of the Navy,
I happened to meet Norman
Geisler, and he said,
"I'm starting a
seminary in Charlotte.
Why don't you come
down and check it out?"
So we did, and six months later,
we moved the whole family there.
- Did you consider yourself
a believer before that?
Or you were just sort
of nominally Catholic
or just secular northeast.
- I became a believer in the
Navy by reading these books
and then starting
to go to church.
And then when I met Geisler,
who I didn't know at the time,
but to use a dated reference,
he was the Michael
Jordan of Apologetics,
what we call evidence for
the faith, at the time.
And when I met him and
looked him up, I said,
"If I wanna get into this
field, this is the guy."
Right?
You know, it's
like in philosophy,
your friend Jordan Peterson,
if he was still at the
University of Toronto,
and he was still teaching,
and you wanted to learn,
that's the guy, right?
He was the Jordan Peterson
of Christian Apologetics.
- So the reason that I
wanted to have you on now,
and my producer Phoenix,
has been mentioning you
for quite some time,
is that there seems to be
something interesting happening
with the atheist movement,
if we can call it a movement.
I mean, in essence, it has
basically fallen apart,
you know, from Sam Harris sort
of disappearing off Twitter
and having, you know, a
lot of political problems.
That whole four horseman
thing sort of disappeared.
The new atheist movement,
I don't know if you've seen
that the president of the, I
think, Atheists of America,
David Silverman, has
basically come out and said
that the atheist
movement was a failure.
This is just in the last
two or three weeks or so,
I've seen other, a well-known
atheists like skeptic,
my friend Michael Schirmer,
talk about how there is a
purpose and a need for religion.
People fill that up
with something else.
And of course, Jordan Peterson
talking about how
people end up believing
whether they believe it or not.
So there's something
interesting culturally
happening right now,
which is sort of what I
wanted to bring you on.
I wonder if, if you have
any thoughts on that,
just sort of what's
happening right now?
- I think that the new
atheist movement, Dave,
was a reaction to 9/11,
because at the time,
the new atheists at the time
were Christopher Hitchens.
I had a couple of
opportunities to debate him
in the late 2000s.
Also, Richard Dawkins and
Sam Harris, Dan Dennett.
- Even Dawkins, I don't
dunno if you've seen it
in the last couple
of week, has said.
- Well, you had a
podcast not long ago
where you were talking about
how Dawkins basically said
that, well, religion does
have some benefits to society.
And I think he's realizing too
that in Britain in particular,
a tepid secularism is not
gonna resist a radical Islam,
but Christianity could be
just from a pragmatic point,
point of view, from
his point of view,
can maybe blunt radical Islam.
So he's realizing there's some
pragmatic uses to religion.
But I think originally the
new atheism came out of 9/11.
These fundamentalists, you
know, you know the old saying
that science will teach
you how to fly a plane,
but religion will teach you
how to fly a plane
into a building.
You know, that kind of thing.
And so they were really
adamant against any religion,
and they would plot, or they
would put 'em all together.
Islam, Christianity, all these
religions are just basically
looked at with
disdain at the time.
And I think people
starting to realize
that's not really the
way the world works.
That's not really true.
These religions are different,
and they're different
for good reasons.
- Yeah, so it's interesting
because what you're describing
as the push, the
Christian sort of argument
as the pushback
against radical Islam,
I think what we have here is
the push back against wokism,
that people, and this
is what David Silverman
from the American
atheist was saying.
He did not realize that
wokism was gonna become,
I think he called it a
cult, not a religion.
And I think that's
sort of what brings us
to this moment in America.
- Yes, and Silverman was the
president, American atheist.
In fact, I had a debate with him
probably seven or
eight years ago,
but then he left that role.
I don't even know
what he's doing now.
I mean, the whole movement
maybe has pretty much
evaporated really.
Hitchens, of
course, passed away.
Dawkins is starting to realize
there's utility to religion
from pragmatic point of view.
And I know it's gonna
sound odd, Dave,
but I have a lot of
respect for Richard Dawkins
because he has more courage
than many American pastors.
I mean, Richard Dawkins
has spoke against wokism.
Richard Dawkins has said,
"I'm sorry, there's only
two genders. It's science."
Right?
- Yeah.
- Richard Dawkins has
talked about the problems
with radical Islam.
Most pastors are hiding under
their desks on these issues.
They're not coming out
and talking about this.
So to his credit, Richard
Dawkins has said some things
that I wish American
pastors would say.
- So what's going on there?
Let's dive into that a little
because it's not just pastors.
I mean, this is happening
throughout Jewish synagogues.
It's happening through
almost every denomination
of Christianity where
the rabbis, the pastors,
they're choosing wokism,
they're choosing equity
over religious teachings.
- Right, right, well.
- Thinking it was gonna bring
more people in, I think.
But it seems to be
doing the reverse.
- Yeah, I don't
know if, I think,
Christians have
bought into the idea
that politics is sort of
off the table for them.
What they don't seem to
realize is that, first of all,
their ability to
actually be Christians
and live the Christian faith
and preach the
gospel, so to speak,
is determined to a certain
extent by what laws are made.
Right?
I mean, here we
take it for granted
we have religious freedom,
but as you've pointed
out and many others,
it's evaporating, right?
So for no other reason,
Christians ought to be
involved in politics,
is to protect the variability
to preach and live the gospel.
The second reason is,
I always ask Christians
this or anybody this,
should Christians care
how people are treated?
Everyone says,
"Well, of course."
Well, should Christians care
how people are treated
by their government?
Well, yeah, that follows.
Now suddenly you better
care about politics.
You better care about
the rules that are made.
Because if you
care about people,
you've gotta care
about what's going on.
And thankfully, you and
others have been a champion
for saying this
transgenderism issue,
particularly on children,
should be off limits.
And pastors even are afraid
to talk about it, Dave.
It's crazy.
- I know it's crazy,
and I see it every day.
And that's why one of the
things that's been interesting
for me as someone
who's not Christian,
and certainly a certain
set of Christians
might have some issues
with my lifestyle
and everything else.
I have found
generally, especially
evangelical Christians,
to be the most welcoming,
decent people out there,
which did help me,
I think, evolve
in some ways in my thinking.
- Yeah, you had a, I
just re-listened to it.
It was four years ago,
that dialogue you had
with my friend John
Lennox and Justin Briley.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Lennox.
- That was a great event.
- If every Christian
was like John Lennox,
the whole world would
be Christianized,
because you can't not
like John Lennox, right?
- He's just a fun guy, smiling.
He's telling you this and
jokey, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He's like your favorite uncle
who has all these great stories,
and John is just one of
the guys I look up to
in my field of work because
he is just so affable
but yet so intelligent.
He's a PhD in mathematics
and philosophy. He's amazing.
- So, okay.
So I would just wanna return
to the title for a moment.
"I don't have enough
faith to be an atheist."
I think from an American sort
of broad cultural perspective,
most people, it's not
that they're atheist,
but they just sort of don't
know what they believe.
We have just sort
of a set of things
that we kind of wake
up to every day,
a culture war, a political fire,
and then that's kind of
what they believe in,
the thing that's happening sort
of every day at the moment.
And I think that
sort of leads people
to a degree of craziness.
So how would you unfurl, if you
think that's a fair premise,
how would you kind of
unfurl people out of that?
- Well, there's two questions
that need to be answered.
Does God exist, and if
so, what has he said?
Those are the two big questions.
- All right, let's do it.
- Right?
- Okay, let's go.
- So does God exist?
I think when somebody asks
me, how do I know God exists?
I say, "I know God
by his effects."
If there's a creation,
and there is,
this universe had a beginning
as even atheists are admitting,
then there has to be a creator.
The creation is the effect
that causes the creator.
- So they might say
it's the Big Bang,
and it was just a bunch of gases
and this, well, they
wouldn't say miracle,
but they would say just
this thing happened,
this causeless thing happened.
- They will say that,
but it seems to me
that if space, time and
matter had a beginning,
the only thing that could
have caused that is something
that transcends space,
time and matter.
In other words, the cause
must be spaceless, timeless,
immaterial, powerful to create
the universe out of nothing,
personal in order
to choose to create.
Because impersonal forces
don't make choices.
Only a person can make a choice
to go from nothingness
to a state of creation.
The cause would also
have to be intelligent
to have a mind to make a choice.
So I always ask people, I say,
"When you think about a
spaceless, timeless, immaterial,
powerful, personal, intelligent
cause, who do you think of?"
And most people say God,
but then they'll say, well,
how do you know it's
the Christian god,
and the answer is,
we don't know if it's the
Christian god, unless,
because this god could be Allah
or some other
theistic god, right?
Unless Jesus rose from the dead.
And if you can discover
that Jesus really did
rise from the dead,
then we can say
that the same being
that walked out of the
tomb 1,990 years ago
is the same being
who's divine nature created
the universe out of nothing.
So you've gotta,
you don't get all the way
to Jesus from one argument.
But if you can show that
the universe had a beginning
and had a beginner
with those attributes,
and you can see that
Jesus rose in the dead,
then you can show that
Christianity is true.
And that's just one of
several arguments for God.
- Yeah, feel free to
make a couple others.
Why don't we go through
a couple others?
- Yeah, the second
is the teleological
or the design argument,
which is so incredibly
difficult to explain
from an atheistic perspective
that even Christopher
Hitchens said,
I don't know how to
explain this one, right?
For example, the
gravitational force,
if it were altered by more
than 1 in 10 to the 40th power,
that's one part in one
with 40 zeros following it,
we wouldn't exist.
An illustration I
like to give is this.
If you were to take the entire
North American continent
from Central America all
the way to Greenland,
stack it in dimes to
the moon, 238,000 miles,
then do that on a billion other
North American continents.
Take all those dimes,
put 'em in one pile,
mark one dime red, mix it
in, blindfold a friend,
throw 'em on the pile,
say pick one dime.
The chances he would
pick that one red dime
is one chance in 10
to the 40th power.
He's not gonna pick
that dime, right?
So the implication here is,
and this is just one of several
factors about the universe,
change any one of
them, we're not here.
Is that what best explains that?
Chance, whatever that
means, or design.
I mean, either this value
was designed or it wasn't.
And it seems, if we're
gonna be rational,
we have to say it's designed.
And as I say, it's
just one of several.
So that's one aspect
of the design argument.
Then when you get to
biology, and you see
that in every one of your
a hundred trillion cells,
there's a software program
3.5 billion letters long.
I mean, if we were to go
out to the beach right here
right now, Dave, and we're
walking along Miami Beach,
and it says, "John
loves Mary" in the sand.
We wouldn't go, oh,
the waves did that.
Or, you know, crabs
came out of the water
and made that message.
No, we'd say that that message
had to come from a mind.
Well, what happens
when we find a message
that's 3.5 billion letters long
in every one of our a
hundred trillion cells?
If John loves Mary
requires a mind,
doesn't a message 3.5 billion
letters long require a mind?
Seems to me that's an effect
that needs a cause like God.
And then of course,
the third argument that
we often talk about,
which is probably most germane
to the topics you talk about,
is the moral argument.
Because if there's no God,
everything's just a
matter of opinion.
There's no standard beyond us,
no transcendent standard
of righteousness
that we're obligated to obey,
then there's no difference
between Mother Teresa and Hitler
from a moral perspective, right?
It's just your opinion against
somebody else's opinion.
And so that argument, I think,
probably carries the most
weight with people today.
- Right, so is that
the one you think
that maybe led us to so
much of the craziness today,
when we're debating,
as my friend Douglas
Murray often says,
things that we've
put to bed years ago,
and suddenly we're
debating, you know,
whether boys or girls
are girls or boys,
it's because we have sort
of no moral basis anymore
at scale in society.
- Yeah, yeah, it's
a free-for-all.
But the very people that are
arguing for that are arguing
as if there's a moral right
to do this, you notice,
because everybody's trying
to oppose a moral position.
The only question is
who's moral position?
Now, all laws
legislate morality.
The only question
is whose morality?
And what I try and
say to people is,
I don't wanna
legislate my morality,
I don't wanna legislate
your morality,
I wanna legislate the morality,
the one Thomas Jefferson
said was self-evident.
So that self-evident morality
upon which this nation
was found is the morality
we ought to get back to,
even though they were
inconsistent with it.
Obviously on slavery
and other issues,
they were inconsistent, but
they knew in their hearts,
in fact, Jefferson and
the founding fathers knew
that slavery was
gonna be an issue,
that it wasn't morally right.
They just couldn't figure out
how to get rid of
it at the time.
- As I tell people all the time,
he was writing the
documents to free the slaves
as he himself was a slave owner.
He was just a man of his
time, as incredible as he was.
What would you say to the line,
one of the things that I think
shifted me on a lot of this,
Jordan Peterson, you know,
when we toured together,
it would come up literally
every single night.
People would say, "Please
define God, explain God.
How did you become a believer?"
And, and the short answer,
he really didn't
like that question.
Not because he didn't
think it was valuable,
but because it was just
coming up all the time.
And he felt that there's so
many other things to talk about
and everything else, but the
simplest version of it would be
that he behaves as
if God exists, that's
what he would say.
And I thought that
that was pretty solid,
that that was almost
enough for most people.
Do you think that that's fair?
- Well, the question-
- That he can't sit there and
tell you, okay, God exists,
but he will behave
in such a way.
- Right, I think Jordan takes
more of a utilitarian approach
to God, that whether
he exists or not,
we better believe in him.
Because if we don't, it's
gonna be, as Dostoevsky said,
you know, if if there is no God,
everything's permissible, right?
It's gonna be chaos as
Nietzsche pointed out.
However, I think there's
evidence that God exists,
and I think you can show
beyond a reasonable doubt.
Not beyond all doubt. I
could be wrong, right?
But I think that God does exist.
And if Jesus rose from the dead,
and I think we can give
evidence that he did,
then the Christian
god is the true god.
So if that's the
case, who is God?
God in the abstract is
spaceless, timeless, immaterial,
powerful, personal
and intelligent.
In the flesh, he's Jesus.
He adds humanity to his deity.
And he comes to Earth,
not to give us some
sort of new moral code,
but to be our substitute.
He is the one that lives the
perfect life in our place.
So by trusting in him,
we can have our moral
transgressions forgiven,
and we can be given
his righteousness.
So Christianity, contrary
to what many will say,
is not a system that tries
to get you to live better.
Christianity is a system
that tries to get you to
accept the substitute.
And because you do
accept the substitute,
out of gratitude for
what he's done for you,
then you will live a moral life.
It's a result, in other words.
- So what would the role
of, in your perfect world,
what would the role
of Christianity be
in, say, the United States?
- Well, I believe in
freedom of religion.
And I think God does too.
Otherwise, he'd be pestering
us all the time, right?
He gives us enough freedom
in order to go our own way.
So I think we have
freedom of religion,
and I would not want any sort
of theocratic government.
But I think what people
confuse, Dave, on this issue is,
I just remember, I'll bring
up a name from the past.
Remember old Chris Matthews?
- Of course.
Before MSNBC went
completely insane.
- (laughs) That's right.
- He was like kind of
hanging on by a thread.
- That's right, he used to say,
"We can't set up some
sort of theocracy."
And I would say, "Chris,
we're not talking about
telling people where, when,
how, or if to worship.
We're not telling 'em they
have to be a certain religion."
That would be
establishing a religion.
But we can't avoid
telling people
how they ought to
treat one another.
And that's legislating morality,
and everybody's
trying to do that.
- It's what the wokesters
are doing right now.
That was your point.
- Yes, that's what
they're doing.
The only question
is whose morality?
So I think,
and I'll part with some of
my Christian friends here,
this country was not
founded on Christianity.
It was founded on the moral law
consistent with Christianity.
When Jefferson says we hold
these truths to be self-evident,
that we're endowed
by our creator,
what he wanted to do was
have a new government
that wasn't completely
relativistic and have no god,
but he didn't want a government,
like they came from
England that said,
you gotta be a member of
the Church of England.
He wanted to have the
best of both worlds,
religious freedom but
also moral absolutes
that come from God.
So he said, we're
gonna establish this
on the moral law that
comes from God's nature.
That moral law we know
comes from the same god
that wrote the Bible
or inspired the Bible.
But you don't have to be
a Christian to know it.
You don't have to be a
Christian to be a citizen here.
This nation is open to everyone.
That's the kind of government
I think we ought to have.
- Is that the brilliance
of the line self-evident
more than anything else?
Because, again, when I quote
this line about Douglas Murray
that we're debating things
that shouldn't be
debated anymore.
It seems to me we're in
this odd spot right now
where culturally nothing
self-evident anymore.
There's nothing
that's just settled.
What is settled
anymore? Nothing.
Was JFK assassinated?
Did we go to the moon?
Are boys girls, et
cetera, et cetera.
- Oh, yeah, it is
crazy in that regard.
And I think part of
that is what happens,
to use a biblical phrase,
that when you suppress
the truth long enough,
God gives you up
to a depraved mind.
I mean, to the point
where you don't even know
there's a difference
between boys and girls.
By the way, transgenderism
presupposes men and women.
Because if I'm a man,
and I think I'm a woman,
I have to have some
idea what a man is
and some idea what a woman is
to know I have this mismatch
between my psychology
and my biology.
If there weren't fixed genders,
I wouldn't be able to know that.
Also, if I'm gonna try and
make the so-called transition,
I have to have some
idea what a man is
and some idea what a woman is
in order to make the transition.
So on one hand
they're trying to say,
"Oh, gender's completely fluid."
On the other hand, it
would be impossible.
Transgenders would be impossible
if there weren't fixed genders.
- You know, it's interesting
'cause one of the things
I've been talking about on the
show, it's the same argument,
I've made it slightly
different way,
which is that with kids,
they're taking a young boy
who maybe likes the
color pink or Barbie.
On one hand, they're telling
you none of this matters.
And on the other
hand they're saying,
"Oh, he likes pink and Barbie,
thus he must be a girl."
- That's right.
- So it's the most
radically authoritarian,
while it's also saying
it's the most tolerant
and diverse and everything else,
which I suppose that
doesn't surprise you
because it's disconnected from.
- It is.
When you move away from God,
even just say a generic god,
the god of right and wrong,
when you move away from
that, God's a gentleman.
He gives up on you.
Eventually, he says, "I
know you don't want me.
So I'm gonna pull myself away."
God is not gonna force you
into his presence
against your will.
And from a theological
perspective, that's
what hell is.
Hell is separation from God
because God will not force
you into his presence
against your will.
I always say, if you
don't want God now,
you're not gonna
want him in eternity.
Why would he say, "You're
with me now in eternity?"
No, he's gonna pull himself
away, and the problem is,
if this is true, if
Christianity's true,
and I think it is,
then the worst place you
can be is separated from God
because he is the
source of all love.
He is the source of all
goodness. He is the standard.
I mean, you've been
talking about this.
You've been talking about,
there's gotta be some sort
of transcendence out there.
- There has to be
something beyond this.
- Yeah, that's right.
- It's not just this.
It's just not just this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I know that much.
- And maybe that's
part of the reason,
going back to your
original question, Dave,
that the new atheism
doesn't or has faded away
'cause people know there's
something transcendent.
We're not just
molecular machines.
We're not just moist robots.
And if we are moist robots,
why should we believe
atheism is true?
We shouldn't
believe our thoughts
because our thoughts
are completely driven
by the laws of physics
according to them.
So materialism is
really self-defeating.
And that's the main
atheistic view now.
In fact, Thomas Nagle,
who I think John Lennox
mentioned in your
dialogue with him,
he's an NYU professor,
wrote a book about 12 years
ago called "Mind and Cosmos"
where he said, even though
he's an atheist, he said,
I'm trying to
remember the subtitle.
He said something like,
"Why the Neo Darwinian
materialistic
viewpoint of the world
is almost certainly false."
And he got so much pushback
from his fellow atheist
because he's essentially
saying, "Look,
I know there's something
transcendent out there.
I'm an atheist. I don't
know how to explain it."
But materialism
isn't the answer.
Materialism makes
us moist robots.
Why should anyone listen to me?
Why should I listen to myself?
- Well, it's just not that
fun. It's not that sellable.
I think that that's
part of it also.
There's no imagination there.
I don't know if you saw it,
but I got into a bit of
a debate about belief,
taking the believer
side with Bill Maher
on his podcast not too long ago.
And it just struck me as,
oh, you don't believe in any
anything sort of magical,
it's like that's such a
fundamental part of being human.
Whether we could
whittle this down
into the firm belief
in Christianity or
any other religion,
that the need to believe
is just innate to humans.
You will believe in
something one way or another.
- Yeah, and you've
mentioned this,
and Jordan Peterson
has mentioned this.
Everybody has some kind of god.
There's a hierarchy of values.
And there's something at the top
of all of our priority lists.
- So what would you
say, so you mentioned
you've debated Christopher
Hitchens on this.
When you look at
someone like Hitch
or you look at say Carl Sagan
or even Albert Einstein,
the people that were sort of,
I don't know that
Einstein was fully not,
he thought that God didn't
play dice with the universe,
was the famous line.
But when you look at the people
that were sort of
not religious per se,
somewhat separated from belief,
but clearly lived good,
inquisitive, interesting lives,
you know, didn't do harm
as far as I can tell,
something like that,
what what would you say
about that sort of character,
that that person.
- Well, I've certainly
have always said,
and I said this to Hitchens
several times when I said,
"Christopher, I'm not saying
that since you're an atheist,
you can't do good things."
I'm not saying you don't
know what right and wrong is.
Everybody does.
What I'm saying is
you can't justify
what right and wrong is.
You can know it,
and you can do it,
but you can't justify
why it's good.
If there's no God,
it's just your opinion.
I sometimes give an analogy.
I notice there's a lot
of speed limit signs
around here in Miami.
- Have you seen
these people drive?
We have a lot of
different cultures here.
It's a real thing.
- (laughs) And there's
cameras everywhere anyway.
You can go outside and see
speed limit 35 miles an hour,
and you can obey
that speed limit sign
while you deny there's
a traffic authority.
But there would be
no speed limit sign
unless there was a
traffic authority.
The same thing is true with God.
You can know that
say murder's wrong
and deny there's a God,
and you can not murder,
do good things, and
deny there's a God.
But it wouldn't
be wrong to murder
from an objective point of
view unless there was a God.
- And what would Hitch's
answer have been on that?
Or what was it?
- Well, hitch was so
rhetorically gifted,
he would never directly
answer a question.
(Dave laughs)
And here's, look, I don't
try and judge my own debates,
but I will say this, the
first debate I ever had,
other than with my wife,
which I lose repeatedly,
but the first debate I ever had
was against
Christopher Hitchens.
And during the debate,
literally, Dave,
I was sitting there
going, "I like this guy."
I didn't even know what
he was talking about
'cause he was all over the map.
But, you know, just his accent
and his wit.
- Great way about him.
- He was just
fabulous, you know,
and I'm kind of daydreaming
going, "I really like this guy."
And I think people
in the audience,
when they're
watching the debate,
they're doing the same thing.
But if you look at the
transcript of the debate,
and you're reading
it, you're going,
"What's he talking about?
This has nothing to do
with even the topic."
You know, the first debate
was called "Does God Exist?"
So I got up and I tried to
give some of the arguments
we already mentioned.
You know, what he got
up and started doing?
He started talking about how
Mother Teresa was a bad person.
And I was just baffled and went,
"What does this have to do with
whether or not God exists?"
Mother Teresa May
have been good or bad.
That's not the point.
What about God?
And he just never
engaged on these issues.
- Well, unfortunately,
he's not here.
So we can't fully rehash it.
But would you say that the flaw,
if he and some of these
other people I mentioned
lived roughly decent
lives and everything else,
would you say that the
flaw is more functional
in that it just can't scale?
- What do you mean by that?
- So it can work for sort of
very, in individual people.
I have no doubt that you believe
that an individual atheist
could live a perfectly moral
and good life.
- Not perfectly, none
of us, yeah, yeah.
- Within the construct
of being a human being,
you could live a fairly
moral and decent life
and everything else,
but that it just sort of
can't scale over time.
It just doesn't give you
enough for generations
to pass on to live in some
sort of functional way.
- I know it's gonna sound-
- And I think that's sort of why
this American atheist
thing collapsed
and why the movement
has collapsed.
- But I know it's
gonna sound odd,
but I don't think
the purpose of life
is to live a moral life.
I think the purpose
of life is to know God
and make him known.
And if you do do that, you
will live a moral life.
In other words, it's a result.
It is not the cause.
Because we're all fallen,
and if God is God,
which means he's
infinitely just,
I've been unjust in
my life even today,
just coming over here.
How many people did I cut
off 'cause I was late, right?
Okay, I'm unjust every day.
And if God is infinitely just,
at the judgment, I'm in trouble.
And so I need somebody
to cover my sin,
somebody to pay for my sin.
An unpopular word
in today's culture,
but it's transgression
against God or other people.
I've done that.
I do it all the time.
So I need somebody
to cover my sin.
That's why Jesus came.
The son of man did
not come to be served,
but to serve and to give his
life as a ransom for many.
And this is the only
religion in the world, Dave,
that actually is built on
grace rather than works.
In other words, you don't
earn favor with God.
He just gives it to you.
And then because
he's given it to you,
then you live a life
out of gratitude to him
that will live in a moral way.
You will live in a
moral way, that's the.
- So connected to that,
how much of what you think is
happening sort of culturally
in America right now and
really all over the world.
As you may know, I just
spent about 12 days in Israel
and went, you know, to
all of the holy sites
and went to the Church
of Holy Sepulcher
and went to the Western Wall.
- You did some college
work there, didn't you?
In the Negev, a semester there?
- Yeah, that was 20 something
years ago, a long time ago.
But one of the things that
struck me was that the story,
it was very clear,
especially being in Jerusalem
for about five days,
that, you know,
they're digging down
and excavating and
uncovering history,
and then they're
also building up.
I mean, the city is just
absolutely flourishing.
It was amazing, but what
I kept thinking was,
people don't know history
and because they don't know
history, they can't even connect
any of the philosophic
underpinnings.
So we just sort of all walk
around spinning all day long,
and we need to know history
to know some of this stuff.
- Oh, absolutely.
We go to Israel every year.
We bring a group
to Israel, in fact.
Ellie Schucron, who
is the archeologist
who discovered the Pool of
Siloam and excavated most it.
- Well, we went down there.
It's being excavated right now.
- Yeah, well, he
excavated it back in 2004.
And that church there,
believe it or not,
didn't want him to
continue the excavation,
and somehow they just got
approval last year to finish it.
And so Ellie, who was the
guy originally discovered it,
is normally our tour
guide when we go,
we're gonna go in November
again, and he discovered that.
He also discovered
what might be,
and this is an amazing
discovery if it's true.
I've seen it myself.
He has found a standing
stone in the City of David,
which goes all the way back
potentially to Melchizedek.
Now this is Abraham's time.
So this is 2000 BC,
and that's right there
in the City of David.
This is a thousand
years before David.
So he's an amazing archeologist.
And there's no question
this was the Jewish homeland
long before anybody
else ever got there,
other than the Canaanites
who were there,
you know, prior to them.
So this whole political argument
I think is just
overcome by archeology.
- When you're down there,
and so we did the walk
through the City of David,
and they're excavating it now.
You can go basically from
the pool all the way up
to what would've
been the temple.
- Ellie excavated that too.
Yeah, yeah.
- Right.
So when you're there,
and you're with the
archeologist and all that,
are most of the
archeologists believers,
or are they more purely people-
- Ellie is certainly
a believer in Yahweh.
He's a Orthodox Jewish believer.
I don't know, I can't
speak for the others.
I just know Ellie personally.
But there are
Americans, as you know,
that go over there quite
a bit that do excavate,
guys like Scott Stripling,
who just discovered one
of the oldest inscriptions
ever found in Israel
up in Shechem,
which is Mount Ebal
next to Mount Gerizim.
And he thinks he's found
that near Joshua's altar.
So this would be, say 1400 BC
or 1200 BC, somewhere in there.
He's a Christian, and
he excavates quite
a bit over there.
There are several other guys.
But as you know, Israel is,
every time you stick
a spade in the ground,
there's another discovery.
- There's 10 different
layers of something.
There's a layer cake.
They described it to us
on our walk of City of
David as a tiramisu.
Basically, you're
just going through,
and there's just another layer
and another layer of
ash, and they can just,
it's incredible.
- It's amazing.
- So would you say,
so as a Christian,
would you say that Christianity
then in essence is
sort of part two
or just the continuation
of the story
that the Jewish
Bible came out of,
that that sort of didn't end
purely with the ending
of the Old Testament.
- Right, the Old
Testament prefigures Jesus
and predicts Jesus.
One of the most astounding
prophecies in the Old Testament,
of course, is Isaiah 53, the
suffering servant passage
written 700 years
before Christ came.
It talks about this servant
taking our iniquities
on himself,
that he is the lamb that
goes to the slaughter.
And so when you see that written
700 years before he came.
- Before Jesus.
- Yeah, you go, wow,
there's something to this.
And there's other prophecies.
- So you think that
was like a nugget,
or what would they in a
video game, it's like,
what do they call
it in a video game?
Like the secret thing in
a video game, they give?
An Easter egg.
- Oh, it's an Easter egg.
Yeah, we found it. There it is.
- You know, and then they
know that it's there.
So how do you combine
those two things?
Obviously Jews still exist.
Israel still exists.
- Of course, and there's a
future for Israel as well.
And it's amazing when you think
about it, as you know, Dave,
there's no country in
the history of the world
that left its homeland
for nearly 2,000 years,
came back to it speaking
the same language.
How does that happen?
And in Isaiah, I
think it's Isaiah 11,
he says he's gonna
bring the nation
into the land a second time.
1948, it happened.
So.
And you've pointed out,
others have pointed out,
think about how much land
Arabs have in the Middle East.
We've got New
Jersey for the Jews,
and 20% of them
are Arab citizens
that have full voting rights.
So I'm having a hard time
figuring out why
certain people there
don't want the Jews
to have a homeland.
In fact, my friend Michael
Brown has put it this way,
or maybe somebody, maybe
attributed Dr. Brown.
He says this, if
the Palestinians,
or if the Israelites
laid down their weapons,
there would be no more Israel.
If the Palestinians
laid down their weapons,
there'd be no more war.
- Yeah, I think Goldammer
may have said that.
- Yeah, maybe.
- Years ago.
So we only have about
five minutes left.
So this went by very quickly.
So how can we wrap
this all up in a way
that gives the average person
who's watching my show,
I think my show,
one of the things that
I'm very proud of is,
I think we have a
nice cross section.
- You do.
- Of sort of atheists
and believers
and people of all
different walks of life.
What would be the main thing
that you think would sort of
unite them in all of this,
whether they're fully a
believer or fully a Christian,
or they come more from
the secular world,
or whatever it might be?
- Well, I guess the one
question I would ask people,
and I do this on
college campuses
because I speak on a
lot of college campuses,
and then we have open mic.
The question I
always ask people.
- You don' get shouted
off the college campuses
with all this radical
stuff you're speaking?
- Well, because I'm
giving the evidence
that Christianity's true,
I'm not necessarily given
a political message,
although I talk about
politics all the time,
but it's not the focus
of what I'm doing.
You know, my friend
Charlie Kirk,
and I'm sure you and others,
you'll get shouted down.
- I've been shouted
down with Charlie Kirk.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so you guys
will take more heat
because of the angle
you're coming from.
It's probably gonna
happen soon to me,
but anyway, on a college campus,
if someone gets up
to the microphone
and expresses any
hostility at all,
I normally stop and
ask this one question.
I'll say, "If
Christianity were true,
would you become a Christian?"
And, Dave, I've had atheists
stand at that microphone
in front of hundreds
of people and say no.
Say no? Wait, wait, wait.
I thought you claimed to
be reasonable and rational.
How is it reasonable you
wouldn't believe something
if it were true?
Well, it's not about reason.
It's not about the mind,
it's about the heart.
They don't want it to be true.
They don't want
there to be a God.
Why? Because they wanna
be god of their own lives.
They're not on a truth quest,
they're on a happiness quest.
And they're just gonna do
whatever they think is
gonna make them happy.
And here's the problem.
You can make yourself
happy over the short term
doing a lot of fun
but selfish things.
However, over the long
term, it's a disaster.
And most of us that have passed
40 begin to realize this.
We go, I just can't live
for myself all the time.
If I do that, I'm never gonna
have a good relationship.
I'm never gonna find what
really is right about life.
There's gonna be trouble.
And what I say to people is,
look, if you want
true contentment,
you gotta go straight
through truth.
And Jesus is the
truth. Check it out.
The problem is most
people are looking for God
like a criminal's
looking for a cop, right?
They want to go their own way,
and so God is a gentleman.
He lets people go their own way.
But I think he gives us,
let me sum it up this way.
He gives us enough evidence
to know that he exists,
and he gives us enough evidence
to know how he wants us to live,
but not so much that
we can't be free
and go our own way
if we don't want to.
And that's what a
gentleman does, right?
- It kind of sounds like
the message of America,
if I'm not mistaken.
- Yeah, well, the
founders knew, Dave.
I mean, this three branch system
where the legislature
is supposed to be
the superior branch.
They don't exercise
that very well.
But the founders knew
that human beings are
inherently selfish.
As Madison said,
"If men were angels,
no government would
be necessary," right?
They knew that we needed
checks and balances
because of the
fallen human heart.
Yet the left now, they think
people are inherently good.
That's the fundamental,
in my view,
the fundamental
problem with leftism.
They think people
are inherently good,
and they don't need
incentives to stay in line.
They're just gonna do the
right thing. No, they're not.
- We're imperfect people. We
can't create a perfect system.
- [Frank] That's
right, that's right.
- Frank, I wish
we had more time.
I really do. It was a pleasure.
- Brother, God bless you.
Thank you for having me on.
- Right on, thank you.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality,
check out our
spirituality playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.